you read the title python 311 is finally
here
make sure you're subscribed because two
lucky subscribers will be getting a free
license to any jetbrains IDE including
pyjarm sea lion IntelliJ and more
it's October 24th also known as release
day which means any second now the final
official release of python 311 is going
to drop
it's definitely going to come out on
time previous releases have gone
perfectly with no unexpected last minute
catastrophes so let's just jump into it
the main thing to know about python 311
is that it's going to be significantly
faster
upgrade to 311 and you'll most likely
see an immediate 10 to 60 performance
Improvement in your code
of course if your code already spends
most of its time waiting on packets from
the network or calling out to see code
like numpy functions you won't see much
change pure python code is where you'll
see the biggest improvements
the work to make this possible comes
from the faster C python project which
is run by Guido Von Rossum creator of
python Mark Shannon who's the tech lead
and a small team at Microsoft
this is just the first release in a
series whose goal is to achieve wait for
it five times faster python over the
next four years or so
there are already alternate python
implementations like Pi Pi Python and my
Pi C that can achieve these speedups and
even more but importantly all those
other implementations give up something
from C python like C compatibility or
dynamic typing
whereas the faster C python project will
be giving us performance benefits
without requiring any user code changes
this is still python so we aren't trying
to compete with C or other compiled
languages for Speed that's not the point
but it's always nice to get a free speed
up next up I want to highlight an unsung
hero of python doing great work Pablo
Galindo Salgado Pablo who's also the
release manager for 311 has been working
on what I consider one of the most
important useful yet boring improvements
to python better error messages python
will now show you not just the trace
back with line numbers but also exactly
where on each line triggered the error
this will save years of developers lives
which they can then spend doing more
important things like watching encoding
videos it's such a small change but
literally every python developer will
benefit from it so it's going to make a
huge difference and hopefully even other
languages will take a lesson from Python
and do the same now to some new features
and libraries python311 adds support for
exception groups for when you went to
the store to buy eggs they were out of
eggs and also you got a flat tire just
like in life sometimes more than one
thing goes wrong at the same time using
the new exception group and base
exception group built-in exceptions you
can now easily conglomerate exceptions
together
foreign
group contains a tree of information
about all the individual exceptions in
this case we try to update the database
call an API and send a heartbeat each of
those things failed in its own separate
way and we see those Trace backs over
here additionally using the new except
star syntax you can peel off and deal
with subgroups of certain types of
exceptions except star recurses through
the entire tree of the exception group
and finds all the exceptions matching
that certain type or subclass the result
here is going to be another exception
group of connection errors rather than
just a single connection error you can
also now add notes to exceptions for
when you go to the fridge find the milk
is bad and want to let everyone know the
milk is bad but don't have the capacity
to handle the problem for yourself
you just attach extra info to an
existing exception and re-raise it for
example here's a fuzz tester that tries
to find errors in the function you give
it it tries random inputs and eventually
it finds an error in this quadratic
solver it adds a note to the exception
containing the input that caused the
error we can then see any notes at the
end of the trace back you might find
something like this used for real in a
testing Library like hypothesis there's
also a new built-in library for parsing
toml files called tomalib this is good
because python moved to the autumnal
format for project configuration as in
pi project.tommel some time ago but
there was no built-in library for
parsing or writing toggle files sadly
there is still no ability to write toml
files but at least you can read them
from python now one thing to watch out
for is that toml files must be read in
binary mode
attempting to load a Tamil file from
text mode will result in an error then
there's a whole slew of new type hinting
features the average user should care
about these not because you yourself are
going to use them although props if you
do but rather because very popular
existing libraries will start to use
them and once they do this is going to
make your IES autocomplete much much
better autocomplete and many Ides takes
into account type information to give
you better suggestions and catch errors
you write before you ever have to run
the code that's why with no type
annotations when I hit dot I get no
suggestions but if I annotate the
variable and do the same thing then I
get good suggestions relevant to Strings
so what are these new type hinting
features first up is variatic generics
this allows you to annotate a finite but
unspecified number of type variables
using this new Type R Tuple this will
hopefully be used in numpy tensorflow
and other array implementations in order
to allow users to annotate not just this
variable as an array but the dimensions
and data type of the array as well right
now what type of art tuples can do is
pretty limited but this is an active
area of work in the typing community so
keep an eye out
then there's data class transforms which
will allow third-party libraries like
adders pedantics equal Alchemy and
Django to have the same level of support
for their custom model types as built-in
data classes
previously type Checkers had special
Logic for built-in data classes but
outside libraries that had similar
functionality generating methods like
your init equals repper couldn't
properly be annotated easily well now
they can however as you can see my IDE
is still not understanding what's going
on and that's because just because the
support for this feature is in Python
itself that doesn't mean support for
this feature is part of your ide's type
Checker yet that's why I'm not getting
any useful suggestions in this case but
if I was using the built-in data class
it knows that ID and name are the
parameters to the init function once
type Checkers add support for this
feature you'll get the same level of
suggestions that you would for the
built-in data class then there's the
literal string type annotation that says
this variable isn't just a string but a
literal string type somewhere in the
source code or it's generated from
literal strings type somewhere in the
source code so sums joins and fstring
substitutions involving only literal
strings will still be considered literal
this is primarily to prevent SQL
injection attacks by having your IDE and
type Checker warn you as soon as you try
to fill in your query string with data
that you got from Johnny drop tables
although SQL injection is mostly a
solved problem a survey of Open Source
projects using sqlite3 Python's built-in
SQL Library found that 33 of usages of
queries calling connection.execute were
using potentially unsafe strings this
literal string annotation will allow
Ides to gently remind users that queries
should only involve literal text you
should use parametrized queries if you
want to fill in a query with user
provided information
of course there are far too many changes
to list them all here so let me end with
a gem that I personally am excited to
see
and that's the async io task group a
very common issue with co-routines is
just forgetting to await them it's kind
of like opening a file and forgetting to
close it whenever you're in a situation
like that a contacts manager is the way
to go so instead of creating tasks and
using gatherer now we can use an async
IO task group this gives a convenient
way to create and schedule a bunch of
related tasks and ensure that you don't
forget to await all of them using this
new async context manager at the end of
the async width you can be sure that all
of your tasks completed any errors that
happen during the tasks are combined and
raised as an exception group of course
if you want the result of a task say the
result of calling this API you can do
that by asking for the results from the
corresponding task in 311 and onwards
it's now recommended to use task group
methods instead of manually call and
create tasks and Gathering them
that's all for now if you want to hear
more about a specific new update comment
below don't forget to subscribe and
check out the full release notes and
giveaway details in the description
thanks to my patrons and donors for
supporting me and don't forget to slap
that like button an odd number of times
see you next time